i started getting one-on-one coaching
with uh grant cardone
and uh if you're curious it's 30 000 an
hour uh and so
i bought four hours so i'll do one hour
probably every quarter or so
and um i just want to share the things
that i'm learning with you
[Music]
so the first thing is that the
overarching questions that i've gotten
from people are
you know why you know why would you pay
that much it's so
you know so expensive etc right and so
one of the things that i've learned over
time is like when you in the beginning
right you're you really just need to
acquire skills
and skills you can learn from courses
you can learn from books you can learn
from seminars you can learn from
workshops
but the best way to do it is to in my
opinion pay someone more than you
normally would who has the skill to
teach you one-on-one
i have i have gotten almost every every
skill that i have acquired i've i've
spent money to acquire at a faster rate
than learning on my own
so i've i mean i just can't even tell
you the amount of money that i've spent
on coaching and information
and it's because information is the only
thing that allows you to buy time back
right like if instead of me taking five
years to learn a skill i can learn it in
five weeks
and i have to pay to do that but then
i'm gonna have the benefit of having
that skill for
four years and you know fifth or forty
whatever seven weeks right
so i'm gonna have this huge advantage
for a four and a half plus years
where the other person wouldn't and if
you start doing that again and again
you start stacking those advantages and
then you get such disproportionate
returns on the rest of your time
that you more than make it back and i
can't even tell you the best roi of that
and on anything of any investment
is investing in skills right so anyways
once you have the skills
then you need really the character
traits right and those are things that
like when you have to do kind of
that self work of not being you know not
hating yourself and all the other things
i won't get into that because it's
another time for another another
video but the next piece is going to be
the beliefs
right and these are some of the hardest
ones to to recognize
because it's hard to recognize the
things in yourself because you already
believe them
right so one of my favorite quotes it's
in both of the books that i've written
is that we question all of our beliefs
except for those that we truly believe
and those we never think to question and
that's been
one of the one of the the biggest you
know
biggest blocks for me because it's so
hard you can't you can't look at
yourself
and know what you believe that is
incorrect because you believe it already
right especially if you truly believe it
and so having someone from the outside
who is significantly above you
or further along in their career help is
just
is invaluable right and so for the first
hour that i spent with grant
um he picked out a handful of things
that were valuable for me and so i told
him that the three main objectives that
i had
um from our conversations was one was a
wealth strategy
two was an income strategy and then
three uh
what to do about fame and kind of like
personal brand
because those are the three things that
i think he's he's done really well with
and so the first thing that he
identified when we were talking about
these three things was
you needed to deal with your wealth
first and so you know my wife and i have
accumulated a lot of money
over the last you know three or four
years you know multiple a figures after
taxes
um that we kind of have stockpiled right
and
we've probably put i'm just being
transferring with you guys i've put
about half of that
into equities so basically meaning
stocks
um i buy indexes so because they're the
most stable
like i take a lot of risk in my normal
business right like every day we're
entrepreneurs so we take risks
and so for me i'm actually very risk
averse when it comes to my investing
like i
i just want stable returns i don't want
crazy you know doublings which is why i
don't like invest in bitcoin and things
like that because i think they're
speculative
um and that's another i think i talked
about in a different video
i have nothing wrong nothing against it
i think there will be a crypto that'll
that'll that'll win out
it's just i don't the downside risk of
going down to zero is not something i'm
willing to
to accept so anyways i
so half my stuff is in equities and the
other half of my net worth is in
well not net worth but of my cash um
it's just sitting there more or less
and so i'm i'm i'm right now i'm
head deep into whole value life
insurance uh
single-family homes multi-family and
then commercial which is big apartment
buildings
and looking at the different vehicles
there and seeing you know which one is
best and so
his recommendation to me was buy one
gigantic building
and then don't worry about it so
basically he's like put all your eggs in
one basket pick it really well
because then everything is going to be
consolidated and then you can get your
attention back and so one of the biggest
belief things that he gave me
was that until i figure out my wealth
strategy i'm going to have
so much attention on that that i won't
be able to i'm gonna have so much
i want it literally becomes a problem a
burden in and of itself
and and i can feel it is that i don't
have the same drive
to make just stack tons and tons of cash
because the thing is now the more cash i
keep making
the more it becomes i'm like god i have
to solve this problem right and so
this was something he identified when we
were talking where he said you need to
solve this
first and so that is what i'm
prioritizing right now is
what to do with all this money right and
and allocating it and i'll share with
you guys whenever
you know what we decide to do um as we
do it
but uh it's i'm going to be putting half
my stuff in hard assets and half of it
at equities
and between the hard assets i'll
probably be diversifying
and the reason i'm diversifying uh is
because i don't know
very candidly like i don't know it's not
my game
right i'm an income guy like i know how
to make tons of money
but the wealth game is not a game that i
know and so then it's the opportunity
cost of
should i start at zero for learning the
wealth game
or should i take all of that time that i
would invest in learning the wealth game
and just reinvest that in generating
more income and for me
right now i'm already at the
disproportionate level of return
on the information and skills that i
have in income generation
that in my opinion it makes more sense
for me to continue to generate cash flow
and provide
value to the marketplace and then find
someone else who's a partner
who's who's done the same amount of work
in that space and then
negotiate some sort of favorable deal
for myself like get a volume discount so
to say
and uh and put the money in and then get
near nearly the same returns as i would
um with a partner and then still be able
to generate the cash that's that's my
tentative plan right now
um i'll probably be doing some degree of
single family
and then also some big apartment
buildings as well
and so that's that was the first big
portion of our of our
of our conversation was thinking through
you know the wealth strategy and what
i'm going to do
i'm going to do partially of of what he
recommended i'm also just going to do
other things as well
but the biggest belief part was you need
to deal with your wealth first
all right now if you don't have wealth
then don't worry about it you should
focus on income
right and so the next priority after
that was
not dealing with but talking about
income generation and
in terms of you know what which which
strategies i i was curious about what
his thoughts were
on um on brick and mortar business
and uh you know where he thought you
know the entire
tire space was going and so he
he was much more in favor much more
bullish
on um brick and mortar businesses being
okay
um and then than i am uh and so i took
that into consideration i was like okay
he probably has
some decent perspective um and so i
might i might ring back
i might taper my um
my my doomsday views a little bit um
i think retail is obviously still
hammered but in terms of like brick and
mortar services i think those will be
okay where you actually have to take
your body and get your teeth cleaned or
get your back cracked or uh you know get
your hair cut those are things that you
usually have to do i mean there's
at-home versions of those but i think
that
those businesses will still be okay and
so um
he was like you know what are you what
are you really good at and so um i told
him the skills that i have and
he was like well looking at the
opportunities within the marketplace i
think this is where
you'd fit best um
and uh he's he's a a huge huge proponent
of lead generation and so that was kind
of the second big one is
um you know he he expanded verticals
from
uh doing cars right and selling sales
and he said everybody uh when he made
the switch to going
wider uh was against everyone said
you're not gonna make it you're not
gonna you know you're not gonna be good
enough all that kind of stuff
um and i'm kind of at that point right
now where i'm probably going to
open up the verticals that that we serve
from a lead generation standpoint
because
we're just really good at it you know
what i mean like we're not good at a lot
of things but that is something that i
believe that we are
i mean i hate saying best in the world
but like we're we're
we're premier we're top or we're very
good at it
and so that is what um that was what his
recommendation was was
you've done you know 100 million plus in
a single niche now start expanding those
skill sets to other verticals so that
you can go after a bigger marketplace
and so um that is likely and these
these concepts are big strategic things
right so they're not like
here's here's how you run a facebook ad
you know like he doesn't i don't even
think grant knows how to run a facebook
yet
um but the point is is like the reason
i'm paying someone um
who's further along than me is that he's
made mistakes and i had a couple of
other directions and things that i had
brought up that he said you know what i
wouldn't do that i did this before and
this is why it didn't work or
this is what i didn't enjoy about this
thing and those were really valuable for
me
those were specific to me um but when we
talked about you know specific
specifically acquisition i was like this
is what we're best at um for service
businesses
uh he was like then dude you should do
that i don't think lead generation is
gonna
be going anywhere and so that was kind
of my big nugget was lead generation as
a whole and i agree with that
are not is not going anywhere right and
so
um and just as a quick tangent on this
um you can buy information from people
who are doing
the same as you or even less than you
and i think that's one of the big
misnomers is like
i will buy information or get
information from anyone
i care about the quality of the
information not as much as the source
and so like i've paid people i mean i
paid 50 grand you know
i paid someone recently uh for coaching
around a specific skill and i'm pretty
sure i make a lot more money than that
person
um but the thing is is like you
it doesn't matter right like if they
have something that i do not have i will
pay to acquire it and so i made a post
yesterday on instagram about this and i
just want to share it with you which is
one of the one of the best beliefs that
i've been able to take with me is that
if there's any human being on this
planet that makes any more money than me
it means they're better at something
than i am fundamentally like they are
better at the game
in some way than i am and so rather than
be envious and cast stones and say how
they didn't do it a legit way or
whatever right whatever your
your ego says because you feel bad about
how you're not as good as them and so
then you try and justify why you're not
as good because it makes you feel bad
because you're insecure
instead of doing all that just say just
identifying the facts
this person makes more than me there's a
game that that rewards value
there is some way that they're providing
more value to the marketplace than i am
what is it and so what it does is it
turns envy into intrigue and so i start
looking at them and start peeling up
peeling back the layers and thinking
there's something here that this person
has that i do not have
is it that they're in a better uh
monetization structure is it that they
have a better opportunity vehicle are
they in a better market than me are they
which which absolutely is an advantage
right they had the decision wherewithal
to pick a better market
than i did to go after right and so
that's a decision right they did
something better than me
um or is it that they're better at
acquisition is there are they better at
marketing they're better at branding
are they better at sales are they you
know like there's so many different
things you know are they better at
sticking you know like keeping clients
on the back end like what is the thing
that they
are superior to me at and so i would
challenge you
that if you see anyone who does any any
bit better than you
identify what it is the skill that they
have that you do not have
and it's helpful to think about this
within the context of sequence
all right so it's like are they better
at generating demand right so that's
lead generation
lead nurture sale are they better at
converting so it's going to be sales are
they better at scaling sales the sales
team
are there or do they have a better
conversion mechanism so it could be a
webinar or a vsl or a landing page right
i paid
i paid tons of money for just recently
around copywriting and vsls because i
think messaging is super important
and it's something that i wanted to show
up within my own skill set and then
you know after that after you've made
the sale is it um are they making a ton
of profit
are they tax efficient do they have a
better legal entity strategy and so
there's all these things that you can
always learn from people
and you can also learn from people who
make less than you right as long as you
can just like swallow your pride and i
think that there's something to be said
for that and so many of us and like
you know so many people in the marketing
space and all that stuff they try and
posture and like
it doesn't serve anyone like you don't
get better being envious and you don't
get better not learning
like fundamentally like if someone makes
less of me and they are better at
something than i am i will pay them to
learn it
right like i don't get any better by
saying well they make less than me
so i'm not gonna pay them like
anyways and so um those are my biggest
takeaways um
that i got from grant in our in our
first in our first chat was that first i
needed to
uh focus on wealth second is that i
needed a scale
lead generation to across all verticals
go bigger
and third and lastly um when i was
talking about goals
um i honestly told him i shared shared
with him some of the goals that i had
um and in true 10x fashion he was like
well how do we get to 100 million a
month
and that was honestly i don't think i've
any anyone genuinely asked me that
question
in a serious way and it
really it really impacted me it was very
helpful
for me to hear it was just helpful for
me to hear someone say that in
in genuineness it really got me to
thinking about how i would do it
and so um that was probably one of the
biggest gifts that i got from the
conversation
and so that might not be reasonable or
fathomable for wherever you're at right
now but
whatever your current goal is and this
is kind of like true 10x fashion but
like
it's still different when someone's
looking at you and i wish i could give
you that
that gift um you know i paid for that
gift but like if i can look look at you
in the in the camera right now or you're
listening like
whatever your goal is for 2021 or
whatever year it is that you're watching
that's coming up what if that like that
that's your goal so it's obviously more
than what you're doing right now
but if that goal were 10 times bigger
what
how then would you approach it right and
i think that if you think about that
when you when you 10x your goal you
think differently right you're not
trying to
you can't work 10 times harder right you
can't spend 10 times more time working
so you actually have to solve the
problem in a different way
than you would otherwise and i think
that's what really opens up your
creativity
into solving bigger problems with bigger
markets and bigger opportunities
so um fundamentally that was my uh that
was kind of like my recap
of my time with him i just want you to
know that i had a great
experience talking to him i had a
handful of people be like man i don't
trust that guy blah blah blah like
stop judging people you've never met
like that's my only advice like just
literally don't judge people you've
never met and so um
i see that he is more famous than i am i
see that he has a better wealth strategy
um i didn't get it to ask a ton about
his income stuff because i know that
right now
wealth is kind of his income and so but
like he's better that
than i am at these things currently in
my life and so in that i will
try and learn of him and so that is um
that's my overarching overarching
thought those are my lessons
um from my first one-on-one coaching
session with grant
and so i would pose those things to you
as
deal with your wealth if you have it if
you don't focus on income
uh think think wider and broader in
terms of your income obviously that's
that's counter the whole niche down
concept i do think you need a niche in
the beginning because you need to
develop the skills in a less competitive
environment
but once you win your niche then you can
expand beyond it and that because you
should earn the right
you should earn the right of operational
skills you should earn the right of
acquisition skills earn the right of
scale
and once you have that scale then you
can scale beyond it um
and then finally simply thinking bigger
overall and thinking about your goals
and what ten times
like really sit with it not just like
i'm gonna just put a ten times bigger
number out there but like
really because if you just ten times
what you're doing is like how you're
going to reach it
it's probably not the way to do it like
think you'll have to think differently
about how you get there and i think that
that entire process will be
valuable for you so otherwise hope you
have an amazing day hope you found this
valuable and
like subscribe all that kind of stuff
and i'll see you in the next
[Music]
[Applause]
you